Let's start with the big picture. Ethiopia is
about the size of France and Spain combined.
It has the second biggest population in Africa,
with lots of different ethnic groups. There's
a federal government based in Addis Ababa, led
by prime minister Abiy Ahmed. And there are 11
regions. They're mostly divided
according to different ethnic groups,
and each region has its own government. Tigray
way up north is where most of the fighting has
been happening over the past year. It's led by
the Tigray People's Liberation Front - the TPLF.
Now all this started because of a power
struggle between the TPLF and the Federal
government. But it's gone way beyond that
now.
What you have
to understand is the TPLF used to run things.
They dominated Ethiopia's national politics
for nearly 30 years as the main party in
a coalition government, although Tigrayans
only make up six percent of the population.
It was a time of huge economic growth, but the TPLF
were also accused of being autocratic and corrupt.
In 2018, huge protests brought them down and
swept Abiy Ahmed into power. And right after
he was elected, he made some big changes. He
freed thousands of political prisoners who'd
been thrown in jail by the previous government, and
surprised everyone with a peace deal with Eritrea.
That's what he got his Nobel Peace Prize for.
He also tried to centralize the government more.
He created a new national party that brought
together the main ethnic political groups,
but the TPLF refused to take part. And they were
suspicious of Abiy's big plans to open up politics
and the economy. There was a sense he was trying to
boost the power of the government in Addis Ababa
at the expense of the regions.
So you hadall this political jocking. And then in 2020, there
were supposed to be federal and regional elections.
But the government delayed them, saying it was
because of Covid. That didn't go down well with
the TPLF.
And that's when the fighting started.
Forces loyal to the TPLF attacked a government
military base in Tigray, then Abiy sent in troops.
At first government forces had the upper hand. They
quickly took control of Tigray's capital Mekelle
and Abiy declared victory. But it wasn't over. The
TPLF forces kept fighting back, and you also had
Eritrean troops joining in. They came over the
border in the north to fight on the federal
government's side. But by the end of June and
despite Eritrean involvement, there was a complete
reversal. The TPLF were back in control of Mekelle
and most of Tigray, and they didn't stop there. They
pushed into the neighboring regions of Amhara
and Afar. Then there was another big development.
This time in the Oromia region, where there's
an armed group called the Oromo Liberation Army
- the OLA. They have their own issues with Abiy.
They decided to ally themselves with the TPLF,
which means now you've got a kind of opposition
alliance that wants to defeat Abiy. Several groups
from other regions say they've joined too. The OLA
are fighting from the south, and the Tigrayans from
the north. And they both say they're determined
to push towards the capital. Now when the TPLF
forces took control of two strategic towns in
late October, that threat suddenly looked pretty
serious. But by early December, the government
said its forces had recaptured those towns.
So the military balance seems to be
shifting again.
So that's how the
fighting has played out so far. But what about the
civilians? Well it's been devastating and brutal.
All sides involved have been accused of atrocities.
More than two million people have been forced to
leave their homes to escape the fighting. There
are estimates that hundreds are dying every day in
Tigray because there isn't enough food. And the UN
says millions are at risk of starvation.
Only a trickle of food has
been getting through - nowhere near what's needed.
Both the government and TPLF forces are accused of
restricting aid deliveries into areas they control.
There have also been reports of horrific
massacres. Like in Axum, a town in Tigray
where Eritrean forces killed hundreds of
people according to Amnesty International.
And in Mai Kadra another town in Tigray where
up to 600 civilians were reportedly killed.
Witnesses later said that forces linked
to the TPLF were responsible.
To end the fighting, what Ethiopia
really needs is some kind of negotiated settlement.
But right now, there's no sign that anyone is
willing to come to the table. Let alone make any
concessions. If you found that useful, we have loads
more explainers on the Start Here playlist
on Al Jazeera's youtube channel. Check it out.